en direction 25 maintenant c'est au nord
de micola les soldats russes sont entrés
dans la ville avant de battre en
retraite la situation est calme pour
l'instant mais cette localité reste
stratégique parce qu'elle est
précisément situé sur l'axé odessa kiev
gwendoline de bono l'envoyé spécial de
france 24
vos initiales ce qui est à la fois une
ville qui se prépare à une offensive
bruce et qu'il a déjà connue en effet
tout début mars les troupes russes ont
réussi à entrer dans cette ville ils se
sont installés dans cette partie de la
ville pendant trois jours comme en
témoigne à l'un de leurs véhicules
militaires que l'on voit sur le bord de
la route et qui est carbonisé ils ont
ensuite battu en retraite nous nous
sommes rendus dans les rues dakota et où
les habitants nous raconte comment les
soldats re ces biens sont entrés dans
leur maison comment ils ont installé les
tanks dans les petites cours des maisons
ils ont également volé de la nourriture
des affaires chez plusieurs des
habitants alors aujourd'hui la ville se
prépare à une peut-être nouvelle
offensive car si les russes ont battu en
retraite ici et bien les habitants
disent qu'ils savent qu'ils vont
probablement revenir pourquoi parce que
cette ville est située à un endroit
stratégique
si si jamais les troupes russes
prenaient le contrôle de me coller plus
au sud elle serait le seul axe qui
permet de rejoindre la ville d'odessa la
grande ville portuaire de dessin à kiev
la capitale c'est pour ça et qu'elle
sait que les russes aient bien et ceir
ou encore de revenir dans cette ville
est un petit peu partout et bien on voit
aide et checkpoint on voit des sacs de
sable et les habitants se prépare
effectivement un retour des troupes
russes pour une deuxième raison juste à
côté de cette ville et bien il ya une
grande centrale nucléaire qui donne qui
approvisionne en électricité une grande
partie de la région et au delà et c'est
ce que nous disait le maire de la ville
pour cette raison cette ville est un
objectif très important pour les soldats
russes